hello my name is Bret champion and today
we will look at new visualization
features in version 11 we will focus on
three general areas improvements to the
core visualization functions plotting
over 3d volumes and visualizing special
types of data version 11 has added
labeling and call-outs too many of the
most common plotting functions added
support for scaled axes and updated the
system for excluding singular points
from plots it also allows functions to
be plotted over geometric regions our
first labeling example uses list log log
plot with data that connects the
population and GDP for each country in
South America with the name of the
country to automatically label the
points in the plot the next example
looks at time series of the populations
for the same countries and uses a simple
call out to label the curves with their
names in a way that makes it easy to see
the relative order of the countries
the final example uses more complicated
call-outs with a balloon appearance to
label the plots of sine and cosine
next we will look at the ranking of some
common boys names over the past 15 years
we use a scaling function to reverse the
y-axis so that the name ranked first is
at the top over a longer time period
there's more variation so we construct a
scaling function that uses a log scale
but still with the most popular name at
the top the system for removing
discontinuities from plots has
previously worked for branch guts and
piecewise jumps and functions in version
11 we can now also remove polls and
essential singularities so functions
such as 1 over X and tangent of X will
plot without showing asymptotes this
also works in higher dimensions and for
functions that have multiple sources of
discontinuity
finally visualization functions can plot
over geometric regions such as this
contour plot over a disk
for a more complicated region we have
three circles with a triangle cut out
which is non convex and isn't even a
connected region
the new functions for volume
visualization fall into two groups
volumetric density plots and slice plots
that plot on a surface that slices
through 3d space
the next few examples all use the same
function of three variables in the
density plot values of the function are
mapped to color and opacity to show how
it varies in a 3d region the legend
shows not only what colors correspond to
what values but which region values are
most opaque in this case the emphasis is
on the high and low values of the
function and of course we can plot over
a general region here we look at the
same function but plotted as a color
density on three planes that each bisect
the region there are several built-in
surfaces but you can also give equations
or surface regions to use as slices
version 11 has many new functions for
plotting special types of data but we
will only look at a few of them
anatomical data dates and times and text
anatomy plot 3d simplifies the
construction of anatomical models using
the Wolfram knowledge base while all the
structures have sensible default styles
you can adjust them as needed in this
model of a human hand the muscles are
mostly transparent and it has a green
thumb timelines make it easy to see the
relative ordering of dates such as this
one being the release dates for the
twenty highest grossing movies of all
time
you can also create histograms to show
how many movies were released each year
by using daily bins but ignoring years
months and weeks we see that Friday is
by far the most common release day the
last type of data we're going to
visualize is textual data by creating
word clouds where the size of the text
depends on how frequently it was used in
the input we see that the Declaration of
Independence is focused on the people
and rights and government one of the
cool things with word clouds is that we
can fit them into arbitrary shapes such
as the Liberty Bell this has been a very
small introduction to new visualization
features in version 11 and here are some
links to additional web pages that have
many more examples and more detail thank
you and now we'll answer questions